boa tarde viva é demais dizer vos que
optar por trazer um tema a minha mãe
enfim que você ousar dizer qual é
e ao longo do dia de hoje assistindo a
tanta gente se comunicar por coisas tão
apaixonados fui me aproximando acho eu
cada vez mais do essencial em mim e
percebi que não tinha sido
verdadeiramente inteiro nessa escolha
então inspirado no jonathan começou por
falar da questão do fracasso
vamos dizer que fracassei logo à partida
na tentativa do marfim porque eu acho
que a minha verdadeira mãe no fim são as
pessoas são as pessoas em tudo o que
isso pode significar e é exatamente por
ser feito por pessoas e feito para
pessoas que eu vou falar então
totalmente sem que eu tenha trazido e
traz um tema primeiramente consensual e
um outro perigosamente chato
perigosamente consensual entendeu que é
o sonho e perigosamente porque acho que
numa altura como aquela que nós vivemos
em que nos enchem os ouvidos dos cursos
para nos tentar motivar a partir do
quase na água pra nós reinventarmos as
nossas ferramentas de alguma forma vimos
gastando a palavra sonho como uma coisa
que se diz demasiadas vezes até acabar
mesmo por perder o sentido ea poesia
falo dela dizendo preguiçosamente chata
sendo que só um confesso apaixonado por
poesia santo poderia parecer que estava
imune a isso mas a verdade é que não
estou sozinha perigosamente chato eu
acho e acredito que em portugal um país
de poetas um dos países onde mais e
melhor poesia se produz descreve e mais
tranqüilos para o estrangeiro lê muito
pouco facto muito pouca poesia não
ganharia sempre frangos connosco
próprios programas muito pouco em livros
poemas brasileiro e eu acredito que isso
tenha algo a ver com o nosso sistema
educativo e com a forma como poesia não
chega no primeiro impacto na primeira
vez que ela não chegue às mãos e ela
chega não cheguem a oposição como o
resto tudo que chega na vida chegando
uma forma completamente concluído antes
que é aliada à competitividade e à
necessidade de quantificarmos tudo nós
vivemos numa sociedade profundamente
competitiva começava aí uma forma de
induzir acusarmos nos
o fundo eram os números associados logos
as coisas
infelizmente eles é que eu não estou a
falar dos números no ar mais maravilhoso
que elas podem ter como jamais que uma
pessoa falou por exemplo dos algoritmos
e daquilo que a investigação nos pode
trazer em termos tecnológicos quer em
termos científicos e eu falo da
capacidade que o ser humano tem de pegar
numa coisa que o transforma os pandits
multiplica e transformá lo exatamente o
oposto transformaram os lucros numa
espécie de espartilho em alguma coisa
que nos limita nós na nossa educação
quando convenceu temos que ter uma
avaliação quantitativa e quer queiramos
ou não aceitar isso é normal muito mais
que política ativa
val na prática val para criar uma
hierarquia vai para criar uma mesa e até
ao 12º ano que depois determina se
podemos entrar ou nesta universidade
pois a outra média 23 minas podemos ou
não fazer cagada especializadas para a
reunião sobre preços trava ou para que o
doutoramento isso vai só determinar mais
coisa menos coisa os próximos 50 ou 60
anos da nossa vida e isso começou aos 14
ou 15 portanto o primeiro banho
naturalmente é isso que me assusta e é o
ensino da poesia não é esse é um o que
nós conversamos para estudar na cozinha
nós começamos a estudar é que o que é
quantificável importante é que o
objetivo e não é que esse objetivo nós
começamos a estudar a poesia para que o
que é objetivo nós vamos de facto que eu
fiz em todos nós descarga os lusíadas
nós vamos contar versus nós vamos
aprender figuras de estilo que eu não
faço é mais pequena ideia juiz vai ficar
mais alguma vez ter ouvido falar nelas
gostaria minimamente preocupado e acima
de tudo nós vemos pela primeira vez ouvi
falar da desigualdade social e da
economia financeira das rimas pobres e
as ricas
não sei se é um prazer uma seca e foi no
meu ensino é e tinha tudo para ser uma
coisa da qual eu ficaria afastado pelo
resto da vida
na verdade eu quero ser contagiado por
uma herança cultural que não foi deixada
que nos foi deixada por joão vilar é
primário vieiras porque os que gravaram
discos de poemas e criaram em mim é dada
altura o sonho de querer dizer poesia
as pessoas então lembrando da maioria
hoje o primeiro painel que estava aqui e
dizer que antes se vir se assistindo a
nora programa que queria seguir
eu sou uma pessoa muito determinada
portanto eu passei meus seu inteiro com
a certeza absoluta que é ser piloto de
aviões psicólogo cozinheiro e música
fechadas
é como um paquerador série está
completamente dividido acabei por optar
por exemplo dizia é um percurso parece
um tratamento orgânico e natural é
verdade é que eu tive uma pequena ajuda
foi impulsionado por um professor do
liceu que teve o rasgo de quando eu
tinha 12 13 anos e chegou com um livro
de alberto caeiro da pessoa nas mãos ele
vou dizer que estou completamente
apaixonada por pessoa
estou descobrir um amigo imaginário eu
respondo uma forma austera e seca que
estava proibido por pessoa não tinha
nada e que aquilo era matéria província
primeiro ano e não achei que era uma
besta
hoje acho que não acho que foi um gás
com um alcance muito grande porque em
vivente percebo isso será 25 anos depois
nós temos um centro que está proibido
era um determinado livro ver um
determinado filme que não é praticável e
haver uma vontade imensa de fazer um
livro de cruz falou o primeiro livro
poesia que apaixonou foi goleador
william e roberto carlos e ao livro onde
está inscrito
o meu olhar a nintendo como o girassol
têm o costume de andar pelas estradas
olhando para a direita e para a esquerda
e de vez em quando olhamos para trás eo
momento é que nunca antes tinha visto e
eu sei lá por isso muito bem ser um
passo essencial que tem uma criança ao
nascer é para as que nasceram veras da
silva que era momento para a eterna
dúvida do mundo caiu no mundo como não
quer porque vai até seu pensar em não
compreender o mundo não se fez para
pensarmos meu pensar estar doentes dos
olhos nos programas pra eu estávamos de
acordo
eu não tenho filosofia tem sentido
você falou na natureza não é que saibam
que ela é mas porque é e é uma por isso
porque quem ama nunca sabe o que é nem
sabe porque ana nem o que é amar amar é
eterna inocência e única inocência não
pensar que não vai o alberto caiu a pela
letra e quando alguém aos 23 14 anos nos
dias através de um país que tenta
incentivar em citá não pensar sobre as
coisas que funciona naturalmente com o
senhor aqui na frente do grupo para
manter o movimento até agora nossa
vitória do santos sobre o movimento e
rolar para o gol sou eu e quem mantiver
movimento atravessa cenoura é estimular
o próprio raciocínio para tentar
perceber se e houve ou não pra se na
época que era uma pescadinha de rabo na
boca e eu fui do carro todos nós é que
estamos num país modalidade estranha que
pasar o passado eo presente bairro
futuro álbum 50 espanhol cujo nome agora
não me lembro que estou a fazer um tempo
ficando naturalmente estou nervoso e
apagou seu nome
tem uma frase maravilhosa christi a
poesia é uma arma que é a do futuro
isso é verdade é que fui educado num
país com todos nós que vivo é assim uma
espécie de complexo do heroísmo no
passado com uma espécie de culpa de
presente uma mistura estranha entre o
orgulho e vergonha algum país fez um
império que era suposto ter se tornado
um império ainda maior e aparentemente
do sul tunas reta em um melancólico à
beira mar plantado
eu passo aí todos nós a estudar ea
sofrer a tragédia de uma criança quer do
trono aos três anos de idade foi coroado
aos 14 é uma belíssima data para começar
a governar um país e aos 24 2 por norte
da áfrica para combater os infiéis não
vou mais além de sua eu aprendi que eu
queria continuar mas perdeu aquela vir
amanhã o goleiro teve de recuperar
o uso do quinto império na realidade eu
cresci lá se foi o caso
num país que se orgulha ter inventado
uma palavra intraduzível eu nasci no
país e agora desenrascanço nossos amigos
produtores do tempo da soldado após
sofrerem muito maior do que o território
geográfico do país e na segunda língua
do soldado
e como dizia fernando pessoa é a minha
língua é minha pátria é a língua
portuguesa estava sendo o tal rapaz que
tenha havido uma do novo goleiro em 1578
e 401 anos depois dessa grande tragédia
para a história nacional em 1989
exatamente no ano em que nasci
jorge sousa braga um poeta e médico
obstetra residente no porto escreve um
poema portugal
eu tenho 22 anos e duas vezes faz um
sentir como se eu tivesse 800 compatível
que não se vestiam fosse combater os
infiéis ao norte de áfrica só porque não
podia combater a doença que atacava os
órgãos genitais e nunca mais voltasse a
pensar que é tudo mentira que o infante
dom henrique foi uma invenção do walt
disney eo nuno álvares pereira uma relva
limitação do príncipe valente portugal
não imagina as utilizam o cinto quando
oiço hino nacional que os meus igrejas
jogar pôquer com o velho do restelo
consulta externa do juiz max
denuncie metrô shoppings está a
recuperar a parte o facto de agora é
tentar convencer espera um futuro de
rosas portugal um dia está em um estágio
dos jerônimos a ver se contraía sempre
do império mas a única coisa que eu
consegui apanhar foi um resfriado vir a
torre do tombo do verso sem lugar
encontrar uma pétala que fosse das rosas
giuliano os trolls
o douro em portugal
se eu tivesse dinheiro
eu comprava o império e lava juro que
era capaz de fazer isso só para te ver
sorrir portugal
vou contar uma coisa que nunca contei a
ninguém sabe
estou loucamente apaixonada por te
pergunto a mim mesmo como povo apaixonar
por um velho decrépito idiota como tudo
que tem no coração dos ainda mais dos
que os pastéis de tentúgal e o corpo
saiu de pontos negros para eu poder
exprimir a minha vontade eu nasci em
1957 salazar estava no poder da guerra
tenho amigos que migraram recentemente
um livro de culinária portugal depois de
ter salvo inúmeras vezes luzia danado na
piscina municipal braga
vim agora propor tanto gente
eminentemente nacional que fossemos
todos a ceuta à procura do olho fica
magoada show
portugal sabe que os olhos castanhos
minha mãe apaixonada na boca a boca
eu quero viver num país que não espere
pela morte de inês de castro para anos
depois a desenterrar e nessa altura eu
quero viver num país se orgulha da sua
matéria prima daquilo que tem de único e
exclusivo e eu acredito que a matéria
prima portuguesa e que é nossa é isto
facto está na nossa matéria cultural
o nosso património cultural e muito
especificamente no nosso património
literário e mais especificamente ainda o
at
eu quero um país seguro e que ouça sua
música
laia os seus poetas e vai ser desculpa
mas ele garante que isso não só aqui o
peronismo quem passou sete meses fora
foi o caso entretanto vai achar lá fora
que fiz mas eu tenho certeza no brasil
há uns anos atrás e uma coisa que eu
aprendi porque o povo e naquela época
isso foi um facto que a valorização do
património cultural popular e ouvir o
rico eo pobre ouvirem caetano o volante
chico ouvirem cartola e ouvia um
eletricista com quem eu trabalhava na
minha equipa e eu complementava
rotineiramente e alinhamento olhos nos
olhos dizendo então um dia como é que
está havendo uma boca com três dentes lá
dentro ele dizia se melhorar num doente
e eu aprendi o facto da riqueza do país
não reside na sua economia financeira
brasília na sua cultura claro que é mais
do que positivo nos tempos que correm
nos questionarmos primeiro o que é
cultura quando ela é tantas vezes
confundida com entretenimento
por outro lado quando a cultura é usada
tantas vezes como uma sobrancelha uma
forma de afirmação de alguma sobre ela
sobre e sup intelectual é e acima de
tudo quando nós vivemos numa altura em
que a corda ao pescoço enquanto se fala
de uma crise financeira que já era maio
disse pouco tempo antes de morrer
estavam todos enganados que a crise não
é financeira é uma crise de valores
mas quando vivemos quase no limiar da
sobrevivência no limiar da dignidade ou
pelo menos não foram menos do que isso é
tentar manter minimamente uma qualidade
de vida qual é o papel da cultura qual é
o papel da poesia papel do teatro é
levar a música pra que isto serve e eu
tenho convicção que a cultura serve
precisamente para alterar o paradigma da
cultura é fundadora a cultura cria uma
massa crítica um pouco pensando em
israel e portanto movimentos e eu
gostava de terminar esta comunicação
hoje lembrando
dizemos que nós possamos falar nesta
crise em 2008 quase três anos antes em
novembro de 2005 o enorme um poeta
manuel antónio pina escreveu na sua
coluna viária jornal de notícias o qual
é uma espécie de crise a meus gatos
dormem durante todo o dia e obviamente
seus pais que os gatos nenhum segredo
que conhecem uma porta para o mundo
coincidência infeliz por um só espaço
assim é o mundo criado como vou estar a
criar o nosso mundo a sua desmesurada
imagem porque os que sonham
são dele os credores os gatos sonham
dormindo
os homens sonham fazendo perguntas e
procurando respostas nos meus gatos
forma em sonho não tem folga teriam se
precisassem de procurar comida tempo
para sonhar acontece talvez assim com os
homens como se afinal o espírito criador
foi os prisioneiros do estômago talvez
então é mesquinha este propósito da
nossa vida coletiva revi como nos querem
fazer crer no defis e o cumprimento das
normas do pacto de estabilidade seja um
único sonho e contudo inicia isto é algo
que escapa aos economistas que é o sonho
mais do que a balança de pagamentos que
alimenta a vida e que os povos como os
homens precisam mais do que números
os próprios números saem os economistas
não sabem porque suas senhas e dos
números é uma ciência das casas
o poder diz razoável e não apenas
repetir
somos governados por economistas
o resultado está à vista talvez só
chegava à altura de ser a política e o
sonho de governar ou dirigir a economia
e não a economia ao dirigir a política
sendo uma pessoa
jesus cristo não sabia nada finanças nem
consta que tivesse biblioteca e o seu
sonho no entanto continua a mover o
mundo
obrigado